SCP-096 Vs SCP-166.
The mass-murdering Shy Guy vs the teenage
goddess of nature.
Who will win out, life or death?
Let’s find out.
The Shy Guy is an almost unstoppable monster
who’ll relentlessly hunt down and kill anybody
who sees its face, ripping and tearing through
any obstacles in the way.
SCP-166 is a faithful young lady with power
over the forces of nature, who has employed
these powers to fight against and immobilize
SCP-682 in a previous battle.
While the nature powers of 166 may slow down
SCP-096, the monster will never, ever give
up.
Eventually, it would get to her, and punish
her for seeing its face.
We think SCP-096 would still take home the
win on this one.